welcome to the week ahead from the
spectator it has been another typical
August that is full of the most daunting
and problems which governments around
the world now are confronting themselves
with specifically Iraq and history is
not conforming either to David Cameron
or Barack Obama's expectations it looks
more dangerous and murkier than ever
Douglas what's happened over the weekend
how do things look right now well
finally there has been so international
action on the progress of Isis and now
calling themselves Islamic state which
have been of course moving from Syria
into Iraq in recent months and have now
when the world has really started to see
with the plight of the Yazidi
populations that the the terrible
humanitarian cost of this I Isis group
going unchecked finally there has been
an effort to go in and do something
about it America has done a few limited
strikes this country has sent a
planeload of of assistance of
humanitarian kind but it you know this
is the very beginning of it nobody
really knows yet how successful in what
strikes have already occurred will have
been we won't may not know that for some
time and it may be the case of course
that this week those try strikes will
need to step up if they haven't yet hit
the targets that are needed Isabel and
neither David Cameron or Barack Obama
are breaking the holidays but there is M
growing calls for Parliament to
reconvene do you think it will I think
it should because there is great debate
outside of the parliamentary Kalen
which is about whether or not we should
intervene more whether we should be
intervening that's whether we're
supporting other groups it's not just
the uzd people here struggling is the
Christians who have been cut in half by
Isis The Vicar of Baghdad has been
speaking really powerfully about that
over the past few days and the fact this
debate is happening outside apartment
because no one's in Parliament it is not
good enough actually MPs should be in
Parliament discussing what to have what
should happen so Conor burns and Nick
Dubois to Tory MPs have called for a
recall and they've called for further
action to take place this debate
shouldn't just be taking place in
newspapers it should be taking place in
the House of Commons but so far number
10 has said that no recall is on the
cards so dollars we read that Britain
has sent in some special forces to Iraq
to accompany the humanitarian troops but
Barack Obama has said he seems to have
ruled out ground troops ground troops
and we say that the same way that
America did before the Kosovo campaign
how much can be achieved with airstrikes
do you think well the important thing
first I think is the significance of
so-called boots on the ground to
Americans and particularly to Obama in
this is striking remember that when
Obama removed American troops from Iraq
he said a decade of wars over
that was his it really address when he
was reelected yes he wasn't this is a
Dimmick thing that although Bush had
sent people into her he was the person
who have brought them out and of course
it is that thing of boots on the ground
that is so so dangerous in public
opinion terms in America Americans have
grown used to airstrikes of drone
strikes they used this going on almost
on commented upon in parts of the world
and also Obama has found these drone
strikes to be working rather effectively
in Pakistan I mean yes you use far
keener than anybody expected to pursue a
drone strategy do you think he's
encouraged by success success there and
thinks we can replicate here well it is
certainly the case the Obama grew very
fond of drone strikes and there are
various reasons though why in the
Pakistan Afghan border regions those are
particularly successful but one is and
without being too cynical about it one
is that the world's attention really
isn't on that so that
any collateral damage at its core which
is actually very minimal in the case of
drone strikes but is not focused on in
the same way that for instance if any of
these strikes in Iraq went wrong hit the
wrong people so the world's attention
really would be on it so there's the it
is very parents having said that there
is a very certainly I think the
possibility that Isis can be
significantly set back by a purely
aerial campaign and I think that's what
should we focus on for the time being
that purely doing it from the sky purely
with the intention of stopping or at
least significantly setting back Isis
from the sky in order that then the
Iraqi government troops and others can
do whatever they can on the ground if
they fail at that again then it's
possible that other things will have to
be weighed on so do you imagine that's
the new defense secretary Michael Fallon
right now be looking at contingency
plans to step up more offensive military
action for example can we expect British
bombers to follow American ones among
weeks ahead we can't at the moment
Michael Fallon has been very clear that
our the extent of our involvement is
helping with the humanitarian aid effort
and assisting with air drops this was
just did the he wouldn't go any further
or it hasn't ruled it out there that was
the story over the weekend it if you're
about to witness a genocide you can't
rule anything out that's what sources
we're saying and that's another reason
why we should go back to Parliament
because actually ministers need to stand
on the floor of the House of Commons and
set out what their plans are and what
they are ruling out and what they're not
ruling out hmm
and Douglas is reminded of the old
Trotsky saying that you may not be
interested in war but war is interested
in you in other words you can't
legislate for the quiet world a ban that
can't declare a decade of war is over we
can't declare we've had enough of Iraq
their world events happen in a way where
the public expects Britain to respond it
is so striking when you see events in
recent days to be reminded once again of
the fact something terrible is happening
in the world something absolutely
unbelievable is on the front pages of
everyone's newspapers once again
politicians of public papers say
something must be done but the only
country in the world that can do
something and we all basically admit it
when someone says something must be done
whether you're pro-american
anti-american pro-bush probe ama the
world turns to America it's America we
expect to do something because it's
America that's got the kit and in that
should be a lesson for the rest of us it
is all very well to care it is all very
well to recall Parliament it's all very
well to talk but if you haven't got the
kit to do something there's nothing you
can do